transformers are quickly coming for your
favorite
models yesterday they replaced lstms in
nlp they used to be good at nlp but blah
we now have transformers think again
today we're going to see that
maybe in the near future transformers
will
replace convolutions in image processing
so this paper is a step in toward
towards this direction
you just wonder what is it going to be
tomorrow maybe
linear regression is going to be
replaced just by giant transformers
trained on 5 000 tpus uh who knows
we'll see in any case we're looking at
axial deep lab stand-alone axial
attention
for pan-optic segmentation by hui wang
yukon chu bradley green heart week adam
alan yul and liang chia chen of john
hopkins university
and google research so this paper
combines a
bunch of techniques that have been
introduced recently
uh to deal with attention in
problems where you would traditionally
use a convolution
so in this particular case they deal
with this problem of pan-optic
segmentation which basically you'll see
you'll get an image
and there's a bunch of stuff on the
image like a cat
here and a house
right here and you're supposed to color
the pixels
of the same object the same so you see
you see all these pixels here are house
and then all these pixels these pixels
right here
are cat and so on and then there's also
the background
so all these pixels right here i know
beautiful beautiful beautiful
our background so for this problem
um it's kind of important that
there you you you're very precise
first of all so you can look at you know
pixels or
clusters of pixels and also that you
take
long-range dependencies into account
because
if you for example recognize that this
is a house
and you recognize that here's a wall
right here um
you might be able to much better
classify
what is wall over here and what isn't
okay so
the kind of long-range dependencies play
a role
in these problems across images and
usually attention mechanisms are pretty
good for these long-range dependencies
but they're also expensive and that's
what this paper deals with
so they use this axial attention that
has been
introduced for exactly resolving this
problem
in types of data like images or higher
order tensors
and they also combine this together with
learned positional encodings which we've
also
seen um time and time again throughout
the kind of transformer and attention
literature
so the combination of axial attention
these learn positional embeddings allows
them to
replace the resnet backbone that usually
is found in panoptix segmentation models
with the with a standalone attention so
they build models that are partial
replace
the convolutions with attention modules
or
replace them entirely so the entire
model is going to be just an
attention model so no more convolutions
in it and they perform
pretty well in classic tasks like they
they test on imagenet classification
they perform pretty well
and they achieve state-of-the-art on
some of these segmentation tasks
so we'll go through the model right here
this is a very
very extensive paper in terms of
experimental evaluation
what i want to get into is mainly how
the method works
um and show you what their model
looks like so we'll go through it and as
always let me know what you think
in the comments and tell me if you liked
it or not
uh share it out if you did all right
so they go over a very long
list of prior work which is you know
pretty pretty cool
and here they say their contributions so
their contributions are
four fold first of all
the proposed method is the first attempt
to build standalone attention models
with
larger large or a global receptive field
and we'll see what that means
we propose position sensitive attention
layer that makes better use
of positional information without adding
much computational cost
we show that axial attention works well
not only as a standalone model
on image classification but also as a
backbone on pan-optic segmentation
instant segmentation and semantic
segmentation
maybe what i did before described before
was instance or semantic segmentation
and not panoptix segmentation
excuse me if that's the case as you can
see it can be used for various
various image tasks
lastly our axial deep lab improves
significantly over bottom-up
state-of-the-art on cocoa
achieving comparable performance of
two-stage methods we also surpassed the
previous state-of-the-art methods on
mapillary vistas and cityscapes
so these are various tasks as i said and
also what they don't mention here is
that they perform fairly well on
imagenet
in fact in the abstract they formulate
this as
um in particular our model outperforms
all existing standalone self attention
models on imagenet like that's
you know that's a way to phrase it uh
you just exclude
all of the other models until you're the
best
outperforms all existing standalone
self-attention models on imagenet yeah
i mean that's good i
i mean there's something to be said of
comparing apples to apples
but you can also you can also go
overboard
if you want to make your work look
as good as possible of course you know
everyone
everyone does that and there's no
particular shame in it
okay so if a
we're going to build up our model right
here and
the basic element of this um
model is going to be this self-attention
mechanism now
quickly because i know you all know what
it is but
very quickly you want to
perform this action right here over
a region right here so there is always a
query
and now the subscripts here are going to
be important in this paper
okay so the query is at a given position
position o and you can see that's the o
right here that's the i'm going to call
it the output i guess
that's what they said as well so the
output position
you want to go over all of the input
positions
and you want to aggregate data from all
of the input positions so that's
right here and how do you aggregate data
by
this softmax operator right here and you
can see the key also has a p
right here and the softmax is over the
axis of
p so in particular case of the images
what does that mean
if you have an image right here it's
made into pixels okay so you have pixels
now a transformer or gen in generally
these attention models what you can
imagine is they always
transform a data point
into a data point of the same dimensions
now this doesn't have to be
actually and i think one of the
developments that is going to come
in coming years or months or weeks maybe
someone's already doing it
is in fact to play more with this
with this arbitrary constraint that
we're imposing on ourselves
because it's not really clear that this
is the best thing but
for now an attention layer is always
transforming
a data point here a four by four image
into a data point of the same size also
a
four by four image right here now this
is as i said this is
quite simplified but it is true
in nlp where we always transform our
whatever 512
sequence token sequence into a 512 token
sequence and it is true
here now the output is is going to be
here on the right
and the question always is okay
so i'll go over these um these these
pixels right here and for every pixel
let's say for this pixel
i'm going to ask what data goes there
what's the output of the layer
at that particular pixel and the output
of the layer is going to be
somehow dependent on on the input right
here
now if you know classic convolutional
models
what the classic convolutional model
says the output of this
is going to be dependent on
this region right here if it's like a
three by three filter
okay so you have this convolutional
filter and
that means that blue dot on the right is
going to pay attention
to you know its own location in the
input
plus everything around it okay and then
every single uh data point here is going
to do that so for example this green
data point is going to pay attention to
this region right here now there's a
border
um so there's maybe some padding
but the question is always where does
the information come from and how is it
aggregated okay
in a convolutional layer what happens in
a convolution layer in a convolution
layer you simply have your filter
right you have your filter and the
filter has numbers in it like
three and five and eight and so on
and what you're going to do is you're
going to take this region right here
this blue region
of the lower layer and that's maybe
that's also
you know filled with numbers like seven
what's a good number zero zero is a
purple is a good nice number
and you're going to multiply those and
then you're going to
sum them up and then you're going to put
that on where the blue dot is
okay so where does the information come
from
in the convolution from around the
location
from around the output location but in
the input
okay so you go to the input at the same
location as
where you want the output to be you take
the neighborhood
and there is a fixed a fixed scheme
of aggregating the neighborhood okay and
then you sum
you multiply and you sum across it in
contrast to this
in a uh fully attentional
model where does the information come
from
let's again look at the blue dot and
let's consider it
fully attentional
okay where does the information come
from everywhere anywhere
anywhere at all okay the information
comes from
everywhere now how
how do i know um how to aggregate the
information so it's no longer in a
neighborhood how do i know how to
aggregate the information
that's also different so two things are
different um
now in a convolution i would have
another four by four
grid here that's pre-specified but in
the
attention model this here is basically
all filled with question marks
question mark question mark where how
what what number goes here how do i
in the end i also do this multiply
and i sum it up and i put it right here
okay but how do these numbers
come to be well these numbers also come
these are dynamically computed also from
um from the input
it's a bit special but
this is how attention works okay so
every
pixel gets to decide where information
comes from
and how it is aggregated it basically it
anywhere and how it is aggregated is
dynamic depending on the pixel
if you don't still don't understand it
maybe
pay out to watch a video on attention
itself i happen to
have made one but you can watch any one
when you understand that you will
understand the
um the extension here to the image is
the exact same thing
as with the sequence except uh the
pixels are basically one long sequence
in the image
okay so this would be a fully
attentional
model down here now
what's the problem here the problem is
that pictures are pretty large
so even even something like mnist which
is
like 28 by 28 is like
700 pixels plus i don't remember exactly
but it's like
about 700 pixels and our big
transformers now so bert
a very famous transformer takes inputs
uh
that are like 512 in length and
you already need pretty decent hardware
to run this
and the requirements on memory and
compute scale quadratically with the
input length so
already with mnist you're in pretty
pretty shady territory
um if you go up to something like
imagenet which is like
225 by 225
you're that's bad right that's not
good um so
you have to come up with something else
so people have been playing around the
reason why i introduced it this way
is people have been playing around a bit
with sort of coming up with an
intermediate with a compromise between
the two
so the compromise that this paper here
focuses on
is going to be is going to be a
compromise
where we you remember when i said where
does the information for a given pixel
come from
and we said okay it can come from
anywhere
in the attention framework and that's
good because that allows us to make
super long-range
connections so any pixel can aggregate
information from any other pixel
and not even in a fixed way but in a
dynamic way so depending on the pixel
value itself and the other values
it can it decide how it wants to
aggregate information
that turns out to be expensive right
every pixel together with every pixel
well that's quadratic
okay so what do we do we
make a third method that's going to be a
compromise
and the compromise is going to be the
following the compromise is going to be
all right we still do the dynamic
aggregation
which means that we still do the
attention thing
however however we're going to
restrict back to this neighborhood
region of the convolution
so in this model where this information
for the blue dot come from
it again comes from this neighborhood
right here
and this number the size here is going
to be called m
so it still comes from that m by m
neighborhood so
a pixel can only aggregate information
from its neighbors
but contrary to a convolution
how it aggregates the information like
this what in convolution would be a
kernel the kernel is
made dynamically by the attention module
and it's made dynamically on a
case-by-case basis
okay so we restrict it to a neighborhood
multiply
sum it up and then put it into
the output and we do that for every
pixel now it resembles much more a
convolution
simply a convolution with this dynamic
with this dynamic matrix right here and
that's the starting point
for this paper so this paper does two
things to this it says okay
um we can augment this
by so-called positional embeddings uh
a positional embedding you might know
from the
sequence transformers so if i have a
sequence
my cat is
tall i don't even know what that means
for a cat
but okay what in a positional encoding
so if you use a transformer
and you transform this as we said into a
sequence of equal length and then
transform is basically information
routing the transformer simply sees the
lower layer
sequence as a set not as a sequence it
has no notion of what's neighboring to
what
what comes from where so it pays to tell
the transformer by the way this is word
one this is word two
this is word three this is word four
there are various
ways to do it um transformers usually
have fairly
complicated kind of sine wave based
positional encodings that bring many
advantages
with them um in this case
they say well it might pay a payoff to
learn where actually these things are in
this neighborhood
so they experiment with relative
positional encoding which means
they annotate this neighborhood with
something like
look here in the middle it's a zero
zero here it's like zero one here it's
zero negative one
negative one zero and so on so they
annotate it with uh these positional
encodings now this is this would be the
easy way what they actually do is
they simply
they give the model a matrix like this
and they
learn that matrix by heart
let's say um
so the positional encodings are relative
positional encodings
and they are learned okay so you can do
that you can
learn position on coding so if you don't
want to do the one two three
four right here you simply say well here
is a vector
here is a vector here is a vector and
here is also a vector
now model you're already learning like
all the ways to make this thing here
happen and you're already learning your
output weights up here right using back
propagation
why don't you learn yourself what you
would like
for position one like what kind of
information
you would like to be to have there using
back propagation right so the model
you provide them you always provide the
same vector so this is the same vector
for position one and you have a
different vector for position two and
you have a different vector for position
three right
so um but across all of the data points
these vectors are going to be the same
so the vector one is always going to be
that same vector for all of the data
points so the model somehow must
learn independent of the data point what
it means to be in position one so the
model must learn how it wants to fill
that vector that's called a learned
positional embeddings we've seen this in
many models so far it usually works
pretty well and i guess here it works
especially well if you have these
relative positional encodings and
so this thing here is not going to be an
actual
matrix filled with these numbers it's
going to be a
learned matrix a trainable matrix
that is filled that the network is
allowed to fill
with numbers right like three
five eight and
you might be you might
notice that we've seen this before right
um so ultimately
the information in this blue thing right
here is going
to depend on this
dynamically created aggregating of
information
through the neighborhood and this
statically
learned aggregation of information
throughout the neighborhood
which is a con which is sort of a
convolution
right um because in the convolution
you've already seen here
this is a statically learned
map of how to aggregate information from
the neighborhood
of a pixel so i
think even though there are slight
differences um they
for example say this these are the same
across attention heads and so on
um however i
suspect that you you can think
of these learned positional embeddings
to be
um to be
kind of like what you learn in a
convolution not exactly
so um no i i think i made a mistake and
we'll see it in the formula we'll see it
in the formula
yeah okay
so here they introduce these positional
embeddings
okay so you see that we previously we
had the soft max previously we had
this and this okay so
this is the lower layer this is the
information
that comes into the layer and now it's
it's transformed into values by a linear
matrix but essentially
this is the lower layer and for each of
the
output locations you want to know how
should i aggregate information from that
lower layer
and you do this by this thing here this
thing here is this dynamically
constructed
attention matrix using also the softmax
okay so how should you aggregate
information
this comes from this query at the output
position and the keys
at the input position and now
you add to that this method this thing
right here
which is again an inner product between
the carrier query
and the positional encodings okay
so the positional encodings are going to
be learned
and hard coded but they still are
modified
by the queries so the query can still
pay attention
the difference is the keys depend on the
input
while the positional encoding does not
depend on the input
so the queries can decide i want to
gather information from this and this
and this type of information
so that would be the key or it can
decide
i would like very much to look at pixels
that are
somehow on the bottom right of the pixel
that i am now
that would be the um positional
encodings and that's that's the mistake
i
made when i said it's equivalent to a
convolution it is not because
the query can still it's still modulated
by that query
vector um of how to aggregate
information otherwise you would have
this
to be a standalone multiplied by
the input right here but it sort of
pays off to think of it like what you do
in the convolution so in the convolution
you
learn how to aggregate information
basically based on on position
um relative position to the position
that you want to output
and here you do a similar thing you
learn
static position embeddings that you then
can attend to with your queries
all right so these are the position
embeddings and they
make use of those position embeddings
in fact they attend them
to the following in this work we enable
the output to retrieve
relative positions beside the content
based on query key affinities
formally so
the problem up here is that okay you
have these position
embeddings um and here
are the outputs but if you do this in
multiple
layers right if you do let's let's go
with 1d
sequences if you do this in multiple
layers and here you annotate the
position
let's just go one two three four um
and okay this layer can make use of that
right we gather stuff from here but then
when
this layer when this layer gathers
information
from here the where the information
comes from
in the layer below is some is how
somehow getting lost
right so it cannot kind of pull
through this information to here or at
least it's very complicated
this model extends this positional
embeddings in order to pull through that
information so as you can see there are
two
new things right here the
biggest important new thing is that
right here we don't so here is
how we aggregate information
okay and here is the information that we
aggregate over
now you can see previously this was just
this
value vector and now
it is extended to the position to
positional embeddings
learned positional embeddings okay so
the
this with this you're able to
route the positional embeddings to the
output and
also here you can see the attention gets
fairly complex
so you have query key attention which is
classic attention
the queries can attend to positional
codings but also the keys can attend to
positional encodings
so not only can uh
not only can the
the node on top say i would like to
attend to position
three um position three can also say
well together with me uh positions
two and four are are fairly important
i guess that's what that's what that is
maybe i'm mistaken here but you can see
right here there is an interaction
between the keys
and the positional encoding right here
now these position encodings
they are different for the queries keys
and values
but um ultimately
we don't it doesn't make too much of a
difference
so here is a contrast between what a
traditional
attention layer would do and what they
would do
so a traditional attention layer gets
the input x and
transforms it by means of these linear
transformations right here
into the queries these are the queries
let's call them q into the keys
and into the values okay then it does a
matrix multiplication
with the keys and the queries and puts
that through
a softmax so this here is going to be
our attention matrix this is the
attention
matrix and the attention matrix is
multiplied here
by the values and that determines our
output
okay again the attention matrix defines
how we aggregate information
and the values is what information do we
aggregate you know for the output
in contrast when we introduce these
positional encodings you can see right
here
again we have query
key and value
now it gets a little bit more
more more complex right here
namely we do this
query key multiplication right here but
we also
multiply the query by these uh
positional embeddings for q
we also multiply the keys by the
positional embeddings for
k and all of this together so this is a
big
plus right here all of this together is
routed through the softmax
okay and now the diagram is a little bit
complicated
uh now you can see the softmax
aggregates information
from here and from this learn position
embeddings i would rather have they
would just use it like they did in the
formula
uh do v plus r and
say that's going to be the information
that we are aggregating and the soft max
here
the output of the softmax is going to be
how we aggregate information this is the
attention
all right i hope that's sort of clear
you introduce these positional
embeddings for queries keys and values
and that allows the model to have a
sense
of where the information is coming from
basically what positions
which if you drop the convolutions so
the convolution had this
intrinsically because in your
convolutional kernel
right uh can i
i'm i'm dumb if in your convolutional
kernel
the number right here if there was a
seven right here
that meant that wherever you are
whatever is on the bottom right is seven
important
okay so that's that was the the
convolution
had this intrinsically here if you just
do attention
we as humans we see it in a in this kind
of grid
form but the machine doesn't the machine
simply sees a set
of pixels it simply sees you can this is
to the attention mechanism this is
exactly the same
as a long list of pixels or a
discontinued set
it doesn't matter to the machine so
it's like the problems a feed forward
network has so we need to annotate it
we have to give it positional
information and
learned positional information seems to
work very well
right here though you could think of
static positional information
okay this is the first thing the
positional embeddings
um that now help the attention mechanism
see
where the information is coming from
that's really important in pictures
uh so we add that the second
thing they do is this so-called axial
attention
now axial attention is a
sort of a let's say a trick
in order to reduce the
[Music]
load on a the load on an attention
mechanism so
what does it mean we've already we've
already seen
in sequences right if i have a sequence
a sequence layer that's going to be
n squared connections between the two
now there are various ways to restrict
that so instead of having all of these
connections let's say from onenote
we've already seen wait if we just
restrict it to
let's say only this thing right here
only this
stuff that can be that is lower right
that is lower in complexity
and this in this case it would be just a
neighborhood so that's what we've done
that's this this m
thing right here however we can also do
it in different ways
since this is a set anyway we can simply
say uh maybe we should just always
skip one we could like do attention like
this
and that would be just fine too right
that would
also leave away some of the information
but you gain
in computational efficiency there are
various trade-offs
now in a picture you have
the same options right so you can
do the neighborhood thing as we did or
you can say where should the green pixel
pay attention to
axial attention says the green pixel
should pay attention to
only the row where it is in okay
that's it should ignore the rest of the
input it should only pay attention
to that row where it is in and then in
the next layer
we'll flip it then the green pixel the
same green pixel
will pay attention to only the column it
is in
okay so that's that's called axial
attention but
don't think like don't don't
there is nothing special about this
being an axis or whatnot you could also
define and it would not be called axial
attention
but you could define it it makes the
same sense to say well that green pixel
just depends on this diagonal right here
just
in the in this layer it just does this
diagonal
and then in the next layer it does like
the anti-diagonal
um you can say uh
i just choose five random pixels in this
layer and five random pixels in the next
layer
and that would work as well we've
already seen this in this paper called
big bird
right the big big big bird but big
bird so big bird
explicitly used random connections
in the attention mechanism and their
argument was
well if we use different random
connections in each layer
then information can travel pretty fast
through the network
so what's the problem with these
neighborhoods
right here what's the problem with
neighborhood attention like this the
problem is
that you break the long range
dependencies
so let's see what happens if information
needs to go from this pixel
or to this pixel or this node to this
node but if information needs to travel
from this node to this node in a classic
attention mechanism everything's
connected to everything so that node in
the next layer can simply aggregate
information from here
well that's not possible if you do this
kind of
neighborhood attention as we've done
here if i do neighborhood attention
then at most right because the
neighborhood is
three long at most this node right here
can aggregate information from this node
and then again it's three long in the
next step so now
this node can aggregate information from
this node
okay because the in the neighborhood is
three long
and you can only attend to within your
neighborhood
this means that if i want to send
information to something that's really
far away i
need to um
i need to
go many many layers right i need to go
layer
layer layer layer and this has been well
known this has already been a
like a problem this has already been a
property of convolutional neural
networks so convolutions
specifically traded off the fully
connectedness of fully connected layers
two local connections convolutions but
that means
that you have to go very deep in order
to make long
range connections you can't just make
them in one step
the same problem right here now this
paper big bird argued
that if you have random connections
instead of neighborhood connections
just the property of random graphs mean
that
um you you are pretty fast
in sending information around so because
in a random graph of
size n you on average
all two nodes are connected by path
lengths of log
n this is much faster
because in this neighborhood thing two
nodes are connected
in a path length of order of n right you
can
you can pretty easily see that if i make
the sequence longer i need
that many more steps in order to send it
around in fact it's like something like
n divided by m this neighborhood size
in a random graph it's log n and in this
axial attention
that's why i introduced it it's two okay
every uh every two nodes are
connected by two steps
if if node if this node
right here needs to send information to
this node right here
in a classic attention mechanism you
could do some one step because every
pixel attends to every other pixel
however right now we have to
um we have to see so this node attends
in this layer sorry
i have to think so how do we send
information between the two
we select this node right here in the
first layer this node pays attention
to this row okay which includes the red
dot
so the red dot can send information to
the x
in this layer in the next layer
we select this node right here which is
our target node where the information
should go
to it pays attention to
all of this column which includes that
x that before right this this x right
here
where we send information to so it takes
two layers two steps to send information
from any node to any
other node that's pretty good so this um
axial attention if you stack them on top
of each other
you sacrifice a little bit of uh
of being able to send information from
anywhere to anywhere
for the pleasure of not having this
quadratic attention anymore as you can
see
your attention mechanism is now as long
or as
big as your column or is wide or your
row is
high again this
isn't this isn't specific to rows or
columns
you could do this as i said with these
kind of
uh diagonals you could do it with any
other sort of
sub pattern where you can
sort of guarantee that the overlap
between the layers is enough so you can
send information around pretty
efficiently and they
use this right here so this axial
attention
you can see the formula is exactly the
same the only change from before
is this part right here you can see that
the neighborhood
that they aggregate over is no longer m
by m it is now 1 by
m so we've
seen them going from if this is the
the full input image and you wanna
you wanna see where to attend
what this paper does is it says a
classic
sorry a convolutional neural network
would be attending to some sub part
right this is convolution an attention
mechanism pure attention would attend to
everything
right this is attention then
what we are doing sorry that was a
mistake
what other people were doing were
reverting back this attention
um to a subpart this kind of
neighborhood attention
okay but that was still you know you
still have
m squared you still have o of m squared
because of the attention mechanism
now what we are doing is we are going
even
lower we're actually going one
by m okay this this is with
with axial attention
so in general it's one by m and then in
the next layer we can go
one by m in this direction and have that
property
um and because it's so cheap now right
because it's now o
of m to compute this we might as well
make
m as long as the row itself okay so
their last step is going to be to say
okay we have one by m
right here and that's going to be
the row itself now
you can see right here that they say
axial attention reduces the complexity
to hwm
this enables global receptive field
which is achieved by setting the span
m directly to the whole input features
optionally one could also
use a fixed m value in order to reduce
memory footprint on huge feature maps
which is something that they're going to
do
later on imagenet i believe so when they
have big inputs or big outputs
they actually do use a smaller m what
you can see right here is that
i wasn't really that wasn't really
correct of me to say that it's now
o of m because you you
still have the entire query space so you
multiply
query by
by keys now even if you make the keys
to be 1 by m yes you reduce
definitely you reduce this from
height times width to times height times
width
to this but then you can see
on this thing right here if you take it
and let's say we have this kind of
row pattern and we replace m
by the width then we have width squared
so
again the square appears however
it's smaller than the original attention
the original attention was
h squared w squared right because
hw is the image and you need that
squared in order to do the attention
mechanism
now we've basically reduced one of the
factors it is still
an attention mechanism so there's still
a tension going
but we've basically transformed the
the image we've reduced it to one column
now the one column is still a tension so
this is still
a tension like here so this
now reduces to the attention that you
see
in a in a single sequence okay
if you see the image as a long
stretch of pixels what this does
is basically it's up it simply
subdivides that into neighborhoods so
we're back to neighborhoods basically
um but we shift the neighborhoods
from layer to layer so in the next
layer the neighborhoods are going to be
just alternating right the neighborhoods
is going to be this is
one neighborhood connected to this
neighborhood connected to this
neighborhood i hope this makes sense
so it's going to be it's basically a mix
between if you if you were to do this in
convolution you could do
one layer where it's neighborhood
convolution
and then one layer where it's like
convolution with holes in it
i think they're called actress
convolutions or something like this with
like giant holes in it
that are exact is exactly the
anti-pattern
of the neighborhood convolution from
before
that's what this is so you see their
axial attention
block right here their axial attention
block
replaces the resnet block so if you know
resnet
i've done a paper on resnet resnet
basically takes the input pipes it
through straight
and adds to it whatever comes out of
this operation
okay that's a residual block now usually
this thing here
would be convolutions and convolutions
and they are now replaced by these
multi-head axial
attention you can see there is a
multi-headed tension in the height
and there is a multi-head attention in
the width
and that gives us the property that
every node can send around
information to every other node in two
steps
i don't like the fact that there is only
two
because um well this i guess this gives
a significant bias to
one or the other direction depending on
the order that you do them in
if if i had done this i maybe would have
used
three of them because it depends on how
you want to aggregate information right
like here you train the network
specifically to aggregate information
first in this direction and then in this
direction which might work and it will
give you that
sending around information anywhere
so maybe they've actually tried and it
it just
performed the same so i i just might
have a dumb
suggestion right here in any case they
simply replace
in we've come a long way right we've
gone to like neighborhoods and blah blah
blah
ultimately take a res net replace the
convolutions with the
height axis attention and the width
access attention
and we're good and then we come to
results
so that's it you have these positional
embeddings you have the axial attention
and it turns out that on imagenet
they perform fairly fairly well so you
can see
that models
like a resnet 50 model will get a
76.9 on imagenet which is not state of
the art but it's also not
it's not bad right the resnet 50 is
pretty good
model um you can see the full axial
attention
right here uh achieves a 78.1
also not state-of-the-art but still
pretty good and as they say it's the
best fully
attentional model on imagenet as our
standalone
attention model on imagenet so
where this model really shines is where
you really have to make
long-range connections between pixels
and that's these kind of segmentation
tasks
and i want to skip the tables right here
yeah
their best and everything and go to the
appendix where they have
some examples of this so here you can
see
specifically uh this is the original
image you have a ground truth
and you have the differences between
their model this axial deep lab
and the panoptic deep lab um that is
a baseline for them and you can see
that the the failure cases here
are are pretty you know
show how show how the axial deep lab
is better i don't know if they are
cherry picked or not but
at least you can see that at some point
so
it handles occlusions better it handles
instances better so here you see that
the ground truth separates the person
from the tie and the axial attention is
able to do this
but the the baseline is not able to do
this correctly because it labels part of
that white
shirt also as and you can see why
there's kind of a delimiter line here
here here here
but if you have long range dependencies
right
if you have long range dependencies in
the model the model will recognize
wait wait that's that must be the same
thing as this thing here and this thing
here
and this thing here so that must be the
same object
um it's simply that the shirt was
occluded by the tie
and goes beneath it and now appears
again
it's not a different it's not part of
the tie and it's not part of the
um of a different object it's actually
part of the shirt
so the long range attention you can see
at these examples sometimes
here okay this might not be an instance
of super duper long range
dependencies this is simply where the
model performs better so you can see
here the ground roof has that surfboard
segmented
and the baseline does not
um that this can also just be
you know there are a lot of tricks to
make this work of course
and you throw a lot of compute at it and
sometimes you just get better numbers or
part of the better numbers because of
the additional
compute right here
what do we have so you can see
occlusions it appears to handle
occlusions uh in a better way
and this might be due to this axial
attention it might be due to the
positional
embeddings but you can see that the
ground truth
here has the laptop between the person's
hands
segmented the baseline cannot do that
but the axial tension does do that and i
don't know what this
is honestly this is um
uh you can you can see though the axial
attention also misses the fact that it
should segment this
in the background and if this
occlusion handling you can see best in
this example
where the person in the back
reappears on both sides of that person
so you can
see that the axial attention manages to
segment that
where that is just a mutant person right
here though
the ground truth is equally shaky i
think there is
might be some ambiguity of how you can
segment these images
obviously but you can see the fact that
there are long range dependencies
probably helped with this saying that
wait in this image there's this white
stuff right here and there's this white
stuff
right here and um connecting these two
regions with attention
probably helped in segmenting uh these
to be
the same object even though you can see
there is a break
in the object so there is a break
no at no point is the object on the left
uh touching or the segment on the left
touching the segment on the right and
still
the model manages to put those into the
same
label category
there is the last um last thing
where they they want to research
what their heads learn and usually you
can do this right you can kind of
visualize
what the attention has learned so in
this case right here
in the column heads the way you have to
read this is that this particular head
right here um aggregates information
from
its column so everywhere where it lights
up
it there's a lot of information being
routed you can see
specifically in this here uh the
heads of the people or the heads of the
persons in the picture
light up fairly well so for example this
head right here is probably
aggregating information a lot from this
position
right here and this head here is
aggregating information from this
position so you can deduce that
that particular attention head probably
deals with people's faces
uh whereas that particular attention
head probably deals you can see the
attention is mostly on the grass right
here
and you can see the same
with the for the row heads now
their description here is that we notice
that column head one corresponds to
human heads while calm at four course
correlates with the field only which you
know you can
interpret it as this this seemed pretty
clear but then they say something like
row head six focuses on relatively large
relatively local regions where column
head five
pools all over the image so row head six
which is this thing right here you can
see that
okay it maybe focuses on small regions
though
you can see okay what like here you can
get it that's a person
but in other places um i don't know
where column head five pools over the
whole image
and this i don't know maybe they just
needed something more to say
because they put these pictures here
they were like oh okay the
the column heads are really nice because
we couldn't like these this one's really
nice because it you know
just pays attention to the people and
this one looks really nice because it
pays attention to the field
but we can't really put the column head
attention without putting the row head
attention but then
none of the row heads really
are like super distinctive on the
particular thing in the image so we
need to come up with something that we
can say and then he's like ah this one
this
is there's not a lot of attention so we
need to contrast this with something
then you would think that they contrast
it with another row head
but then there's no row head that does
this whole
image so there's like ah column at five
yeah
i'm i'm not sure if there's there's a
bit of there's a bit of uh
tactical writing going on here i suspect
i mean it's still
you know it's doing something uh cool
but
yeah there's there's a definitely an
element of sales
in when you do when you write research
papers
and just um not to this data but just
props to the lines in front of the
histograms makes it so
much easier to read how big the stupid
bars are
why does everyone put the lines behind
the histogram i probably do that myself
and now i'm just i'm realizing how much
easier that is all right there is a big
big big
experimental section right here and
there's a big appendix where you can
read up all of the different numbers
comparisons
ablations what not um ultimately i just
wanted to go over
the method basically putting this into
context with other things like putting
this into context with
stuff like big bird axial attention
other positional encodings
uh how it co how it relates to
convolutions how it relates to feed
forward networks and what
convolutions did to feed forward
networks and so on
i hope you at least
a little bit gain an understanding of
what's going on here
and with that said i see you
next time bye bye